es ist schon wieder passiert in einem
baggersee in hessen ist ein 17-jähriger
ertrunken
der 17 jährige will sich am
samstagnachmittag in einem baggersee
zwischen groß rohrheim und biblis im
landkreis bergstraße abkühlen
gegen 16 uhr rutschte dann offenbar am
steil abfallenden ufer ins wasser als
nichtschwimmer- sein kumpel will helfen
ist aber ebenfalls nicht schwimmer er
ruft dann um hilfe
feuerwehr und deutsche
lebensrettungsgesellschaft rücken an und
müssen gleich mehrere hindernisse
überwinden
der baggersee ist kein öffentliches
gewässer ein drei meter hoher erdwall
trennt ihn von der umgebung trotz
verbots baden zahlreiche menschen in dem
sie als wildparker versperren sie den
weg die lebenswichtigen
rettungsmaßnahmen können so nur mit
verzögerung beginnen
leider zu spät für den jungen mann auf
facebook macht die feuerwehr aus dem
rhein-neckar-kreis ihrem ärger luft sind
die rettungseinsätze bei
schweißtreibenden temperaturen in voller
schutzausrüstung nicht schon anstrengend
genug mussten sich die einsatzkräfte am
samstagnachmittag mit teils
uneinsichtigen badegästen herumärgern
insbesondere die tatsache dass eine
person ein 17 jähriger ums leben kam
sie sorgte für eine zusätzliche
belastung der baggersee ist teil eines
firmengeländes schon länger versucht die
gemeinde ein badeverbot durchzusetzen
es hat wieder mal gezeigt dass das
letzte wort und im bericht der zeitung
standen dass es beraten hier im kiez
noch sehr gefährliches lebensgefährlich
ist wir haben baden verboten schilder
aufgestellt wir haben durchfahrtsverbote
aufgestellt aber das bevölkerung sie
soll gerade auswärtige bevölkerung
ignoriert das komplett seit
freitagnachmittag sind mindestens acht
menschen beim baden ums leben gekommen
und ein ende der hitzewelle ist noch
nicht abzusehen
und mein kollege tobi beier ist jetzt in
hessen vor ort hallo tobi was ist denn
über den 17 jährigen bekannt für den
17-jährigen ist auf jeden fall bekannt
dass er sich gestern gegen 16 uhr an dem
badesee am baggersee aufgehalten haben
sollen mit einer gruppe von acht bis
zehn personen so berichtete mir ist der
bürgermeister der gleichzeitig als
feuerwehrmann als ersthelfer vor ort war
und das bergische keiner der acht bis
zehn begleiter des jungen mann das ondo
schwimmen
somit konnten sie ihm auch nicht zu
hilfe eilen kann es denn dort schon
früher einmal zu badeunfällen wenn man
den worten des bürgermeisters vertrauen
schenkt kam es hier noch zu keinen
tödlichen unfall in den vergangenen
jahren allerdings erzählte mir ein
angler der hier nahezu jeden tag am see
angeln ist dass er am freitag zuletzt
einen nicht schwimmer aus dem wasser
ziehen musste wer sich abkühlen wollte
und wohl auch abrutschte und sich nicht
mehr selbst ans ufer ziehen konnte und
er eben auf unterstützungen dann und
rettungen des anglers angewiesen war
der tory wir sehen hinter der großes
baden verboten schild waren denn auch
heute wieder baden der dort vor ort
unfassbar aber tatsächlich heute waren
weit über 100 menschen wieder vor ort
die badeten die am strand lagen als wäre
nichts passiert mit einigen der menschen
sprechen können die meinten sie seien
hier schon seit 20 30 jahren am baden
und das passiere doch nichts man stimmen
kann und das verbot interessiere sie
nicht sie würden immer weiter hierher
kommen sie sehen keinen grund daran
etwas zu ändern nur weil ein 17 jähriger
ums leben kamen in ihren augen nur
natürlich tobi beier vielen herzlichen
dank für deine einschätzungen